[Applause]
okay hello holy Sh how are you doing you
guys hahaha wow I never thought I would
be here I am so pleased to be here this
is going to be a panel slightly
different I'm going to do things quite
informally we're all friends here aren't
we
I want to picture yourself you're
watching Game of Thrones on your sofa
close your eyes think about all the
questions you want to ask us - got
yourself in that really relaxed place
ready to put your hand on your heart got
your eyes closed put your hand on your
walls bring it up to me I'll look after
it no don't do that okay these are all
my friends guys these are the people
I've worked for six years with on what I
think is the best show that's ever been
created I'm the first guest I'm sorry
let's get a monkey on my back six years
yes like you do it helps belong here
yeah
there isn't gentlemen my very good
friend
I'm little brother Isaac Hampstead right
[Applause]
then if gentlemen John Bravo
[Applause]
the amazing not be upon you L
[Applause]
they Emporium
it's Christian tradition these guys I've
known them sensor like eight years old
sous Garrett
so see Turner
that isn't gentlemen Jacob Anderson my
fellow Pokemon Thomas Hill I'll be our
[Applause]
this is gentleman who Evelyn crispy
although guys yo look ravishing
absolutely ravishing tonight start the
classes will start the questions and
start the question Who am I'm going to
start with you hello hi hi mommy
[Applause]
okay we have seen the scene torment make
a play for Brienne yeah I actually have
a theory that I think Breanna and Hodor
would make a really good couple get
ahead I've always held a candle to that
Oh
a very small one very small okay the
same torment make a play for Brienne who
seems to be rebuffing his advancement do
you think she secretly enjoys being
appreciated as a woman and a warrior
perfectly well I think it's really what
I love about Brienne of Tarth is that I
don't think that at the foremost of her
consciousness is a value system that's
based on how many preciate her but I
mean who doesn't like being appreciated
as both really but I don't I don't think
that's really what she's invested in at
all I think she's finding it incredibly
awkward but underneath any awkwardness
is always that potential secret
enjoyment what do you all think does she
like it or did she like someone else
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you saying
okay Wow Oh Jamie what Alfie firstly
what'd he call your dog what's the name
of the dog her name is Abby that was the
cutest thing I've ever seen in my life
seriously
I really want it what was it like for
you to return to the character of Theon
after such a torturous rum as reek um
I'd say it was it was definitely a
challenge um I'd say that he wasn't
really kind of stepping into the feeling
that he was before
he was turned into reek but yeah he's
just he's had to definitely a crazy arc
of many of the characters on the show
he's been one of the the craziest but
it's um it's just been enjoyable you
know to be able to find empathy for a
character such as him amazing thank you
Alfie Connor we've never actually had an
opportunity to act together which is
terrible many of your fellow cast site
how difficult it can be to keep from
laughing while filming with you do you
purposefully make them laugh now and is
there an actor he makes you laugh they
all make me laugh and sometimes they
know it but mostly they don't but
Dinklage would make me laugh a lot yeah
yeah yeah there's some pretty funny
people in the cast that's for sure
not you Jacob
hello hi that's not how a citizen ought
hello hello is it true that we've seen
grey worm being a bit flirtatious with
Miss in die and do you see a future for
them uh yeah I mean I think there's
already this thing's firing between them
this is this chemistry right I think um
yeah I want those kids to be happy I
want them to find happiness with each
other everything so sad in never going
to happen
nothing's ever going to be happy you
know do you think Daenerys would approve
of that relationship yeah I think she's
like she'd do the wedding she'd like
which don't call a wedding do you it's
not bingo
yeah I think she'd be involved yeah
awesome not involved
oh okay that's a completely different
show I think you would all watch it
though wouldn't it totally Sophie is
that set up is Samsa being manipulated
by Littlefinger or is she playing the
long game ah good question
um yeah I think initially you know there
was definite manipulation on
Littlefinger's part but you know as
Sansa has grown and been you know a
prisoner by all of these master
manipulators especially Littlefinger
she's been silently absorbing and
learning and adapting and in my opinion
she's just as good at playing the game
as he is at this point thanks guys I
love her limb hello look at this a rose
between two thorns ah don't say that go
ahead
answer question at the end of last
season
Davos find out about misbehaving readers
I really need to wear my glasses
Melisandre's part in Sharon's death Jon
Snow banished her from the north and
Davos said he would kill her if she ever
returned do you think he would and does
he have it in him to murder someone in
cold blood I think that's a good
question I don't I don't think he's the
vindictive type I think if he was on the
road taking a long weekend somewhere and
in the opposite direction he saw a lady
in a red cape approaching I think
there's a good chance he'd whip out a
Glock and pop a couple of caps in her
ass hahaha but I don't think he'd hunt
her down I don't think he doing are you
I don't think he's got a list but there
but I definitely think he'd put her in a
shallow grave somewhere if no one was
gonna find out now that's just me can
you just quickly show us how you'd hold
a Glock
yeah I hold a sideways my leg in the
hole yeah I love it
Natalie hi hello there was a great scene
with Tyrion and grey worm last season
when terian was exhorting you both to
drink yeah missandei goggles we saw them
we saw them that machine died and grey
worm we're going growing closer how do
you hope that storyline pans out
I feel quite similarly to Jacob I'm like
I want these guys to be happy and you
know just stay together I think they've
come through so much atrocity so to see
them laugh together and like feels
something for another person is so
beautiful and I've really enjoyed
portraying that journey and I hope we
get to see it blossom more and maybe
there might be a happy ending for them I
don't say it just in case that's death I
know how it feels I know how John hello
hello Sam has always considered himself
a Bevin outsider ya have Gilly and baby
Sam given him a sense of belonging
I didn't write these by the way he's
easy absolutely always been an outsider
he was an outsider from the day he was
born at home because his father
considered in to be such a
disappointment and treated him with such
contempt then he was removed to Castle
black where he was an outsider again and
then he said well the one place I can be
really accepted is the Citadel that's
the one place I can go where my passions
and interests aren't treated with scorn
and contempt they're the place where is
the place where people have an
understanding and appreciation of
knowledge and and this is going to be
the place where I feel accepted for the
first time in my life
there is just as much as an outside of
theirs he is anywhere else because they
make him do all those jobs that you saw
him doing and and it's interesting that
people say how is him being at the
Citadel going to affect his relationship
with Gilly given the fact that they've
grown so close over the years but that
was when Sam didn't have thousands and
thousands of books as a distraction from
his relationship so I think that as time
has gone on
Sam has worked out a lot of people work
out in relationships that you're your
kind of sphere of interest shrinks and
you no longer want to be necessarily
accepted by a wider world or even a
wider community because you know what's
important and important is being loved
by two people rather than accepted by
hundreds yeah good answer good answer
man this is a very important question do
you miss me no because I do know it's
been so empty without you on set such a
liar okay seriously making me sailors
help me know okay that's actually as a
question which you know as a fan of the
show and I've been there for six years
what the hell's neom is that the Adria
van avoid the three-eyed raven what the
hell is that about well I want an
in-depth analysis like a Wikipedia page
well what's interesting about the
three-eyed raven is he's one of the sort
of few fragments that remain of the old
Westeros of the the ancient kind of
magical mystical side of it so what
exactly his purpose is I don't think has
has been revealed yet but clearly it's
something important there's been the
night King is appears to be his sworn
enemy so he must have some important
role to play so for bran this season
especially it's quite exciting that he
is now
it's three eyed Raven and you don't know
them yeah yeah that's my rambling wave
the same yeah okay okay it's very very
informative thank you right this is for
everybody and I'm going to start right
back down at the end with Gwendolyn I
like this question if you ended up on
the Iron Throne what would be the first
law you would pass what would be the
first law I would pass the women could
be nice you can exchange same questions
you healthy I would say the the
Brotherhood that beric Dondarrion is
part of we be made allowed throughout
the land so everyone can come back to
life that works for me Thomas and that
comic-con's are free nice Jacob free
puppies for everyone that one oh and
also some sort of device well where we
can create unicorns do exist I mean I
don't know how that would work but
everybody needs unicorn you do that we
all need unicorns yeah Sophie because
this is really tough the first thing
that comes to mind is just like
unlimited carbohydrate I don't know why
but that's what I want
so no I think in selected outlets all
over Westeros there should be free
Dornish wine for all the inhabitants of
us you're welcome
I think with Sunday would probably want
and I would quite like you know language
lessons for everyone I can all be
bilingual and cool yeah education for
everyone that's a really serious answer
but also true how I feel yeah
[Applause]
how about mace - Guster clean out their
own stinking bed number one I've set up
a holiday scheme for all the characters
who have only filmed in the cold places
to go and film in the warm places I
second that
yes second okay moving back to the
individual questions what about me yeah
okay
I would make it illegal for one person
to mind another and be carried
I'm glad you finish that sentence and
every time you have to say thank you
which you never did I'll try that's not
true yeah that is oh yeah anyway
Gwendolyn you're always my first you
lost your everything hahahaha
okay what do you think it drives Brienne
never give up on a quest to protect his
darks I think that the relationship
between Brienne and Catelyn Stark was a
moment where Brienne realised strength
in another woman I remember quite
fervently that line you have it to
Catelyn Stark you have strength ah not a
man's strength at a woman's strength and
I think it was that realization that
Brienne didn't have to force herself
into a mold of masculinity she didn't
have to take the path of member for her
in order to be taken seriously or to do
good that she could be propelled by her
own intuitive sense of of what was right
in terms of moral comes
and I think that there's something very
beautiful about the way she's projected
that into the future that it doesn't
matter of someone's lives or dies that
that goes into that person's daughters
and it is significant that they are her
daughters to return the stark girls home
and in her own way I think that Brienne
feels that even if it's one small thing
for one person or two people that that's
going to perpetuate a sense of good
which may be subconsciously creates a
greater sense of equality and that's
what I think is driving her it she's
connecting to an idea that's greater
than herself Wow
and this is why this is why there isn't
just one if you've ever seen me at one
of these my answers for basically every
question is always Brienne of Tarth yeah
you would be the queen I would put on
the throne so that's why that's why so
okay
awkward I love you love you too Alfie as
a tree our unborn how comfortable is
beyond with the fact that his were sick
in his way of life to be on Tim Daenerys
you know I think that the the Yara is
really kind of deciding the the journey
they take now do their new leadership
with Daenerys so I'd say it's definitely
an equal partnership between the two of
them but I would say he's just excited
to see what this new leadership takes
them being needed by gennaro Senora cool
condoms how dare you virus is rarely
round what do you think scared him oh I
think the economic outlook and I will
something whatever that sorcerer said we
you know we saw him with a red priestess
we were it was one of the two times
where he looked a bit why hmm
because she was cray ha ha yeah I think
that's that's you know he survived so
much but that's the one thing we don't
know what was said and and because of
your experience with you know words and
hold the door and everything I think oh
god I'm gonna be holding a door for
someone and that's what the sorcerer
said so that's the only thing I'm kind
of you know there's a mystery there that
I still don't know what that's about
what was said and what it means well my
advice when it comes to holding doors is
don't all right yeah or get a swinging
door yeah I'm thinking it never ends
well Jacob yeah yeah some of you some of
you out there may know Jacob is also a
very talented musician well thank you
how do you bounce both sides of your
career um I kind of don't I have I'm
really lucky
um I've got like we the way we shoot the
show is kind of over a period I don't
know why I'm telling you this the way we
through the surface is like it's like
six months and then we're all kind of in
and out kind of revolving doors sorry it
was a trigger um and um so I just
whenever I'm not in Belfast or or a
sunny place just Robert N Montes talk
about doors you're talking about little
time right songs um yeah it's not been
too bad actually it's not been hard
could what my life could be worse I mean
I'm really nervous by the way this is
like I'm at home here but for some
reason Authority why don't you get us
settled in the right song Oh
what song Julian uh well no one of my
songs your nao devices no I thought I
might come you know okay communist
communist off everything that you saw me
up yeah it was about to get really
really exciting I was about to go into
like Italy yeah medley I just thought
was just a device wasn't it yeah this
Thank You Jacob I mean yeah I know what
it's about I know what to buy bounced
into careers I was I was like actually
day gentle like today I'm outside I
don't bounce I just I just do it yeah we
do you ever he just do it yeah Sophie hi
hi those Samsa
retain any of her ideas about love
marriage and being happy or is she now
the opinion that men are just after her
for what she can get what they can get
ah I don't think I don't think she's
like season once answer and she's
particularly looking for it's not really
looking for a relationship or love some
moment I think she's kind of done with
that I think you know she's always on
the search for happiness but she doesn't
really see the world through rose-tinted
glasses anymore you know she sees the
reality of the situation in terms of
like seeing men in a different light I
think she sees the world in a different
light I don't think men in particular I
think she talked about moms her um I
mean of course she's you know she's just
kind of she's woke now guys she's real
woke you know she's cautious she trusts
no one
whether it be man or
and whether a family member or not she
trusts no one and I think that's
important when you play the game of
friend Liam
years do you think Davos misses his
smuggling days when life is simpler and
he is able to live by his wits yeah
that's a kind of an interesting question
because him being promoted from
small-time criminal to being sucked into
this web this game there's very little
room I think it reflects real life when
people end up in powerful positions it
you can't have a simple life anymore
it's very difficult to be just happy
you're playing games you're paranoid
who's out the gate or the whole thing
but I think he felt he had a
responsibility to be there to try and
heed
whoever it may be on the right track and
because he's decent and he's loyal and
he doesn't he doesn't have that
addiction for this horrible drug that is
power so is his head is kind of his head
it's a little bit clearer than some but
I do I do like the guys I love the guy
simplicity it's he he is who he is and
he's he's not a complicated character
and it's really nice for dinner it's
really nice to play somebody like that
and play those little colorism I really
I really love this character I think
that's one of the special things about
George RR Martin's writing every single
character even the matter how small they
are is completely multi-layered
we all get such a grit what do you mean
small I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding I don't mean you I only had one
word I don't think I can compete hello
anyway Notley we know that miss in die
owes a debt to Daenerys as she freed her
from slavery do you think Daenerys
should have made miss in died her hand
instead of Tyrion oh that's a great
question
um I don't know about that that would be
cool I'd love to
play that but I think you know Tyrion
knows the enemy he is much more
experienced with being a hand he and
that sort of political landscape I think
missandei has come from a completely
different world she's been dealing with
a completely different set of dangers
but like she you know this sort of
strategizing and negotiating this very
cutthroat world all of a sudden is is so
new so I think Tyrion is probably the
better candidate for hand and I fully
support him in that role although it
would be super cool to be like hand to
like your bestie
you know like girl power
you know double-team like it'd be pretty
fun I think he would admit an awesome
hand actually I will thank you to be a
thank you I appreciate John mm-hmm when
Samwell was a member of the Nights Watch
yeah Jon Snow was his constant protector
yeah how much of an influence he think
Jon still has over him and how much the
summer want to please Jon Sam no no Sam
arrived at Castle black completely
bereft of any positive male role model
in his life and indeed the positive
female role model that he had had been
very cruelly taken away from him so what
he found in Jon Snow in that moment was
everything he possibly needed all kind
of wrapped up in one person he was it
was a big brother he was a father figure
he was a confidant he was the best
friend it was all of those things and
Sam knew what it was like to be saved by
somebody knew what it was like to be
saved by Jon Snow and knew what it was
like to have somebody take the burden of
you on their shoulders and when he found
Gilly he found somebody in even more
kind of emotional dire straits than he
was who had a life of systematic sexual
abuse laid out in front of her and the
worst possible life you can imagine so
he knew what it was like to be saved at
that point
so he wanted to do that for somebody
else he wanted he wanted to save this
girl and her son because he knows how
important that can be it was like John
handed a baton on to Sam and and John
snow was kind of everything to Sam and
now Dave's dead gone on their separate
paths because Sam wants to please him so
much because he wants to fight the same
battle as Jon Snow he wants to stand
shoulder to shoulder with Jon Snow in
the Great War but he knows that he can't
do that on the battlefield he knows that
he has to do that using his very unique
set of skills which is academia and
learning and applying knowledge you know
if the Citadel his battlefield and so
John sent him there and now he has he
has the responsibility to make John
faith and him justified and get John
results he knows it's a race against
time he needs to get in there find out
whatever piece of information he needs
to find out get back up to the north and
give it to Jon Snow that that's what he
any feels about responsibility all the
time he he knows he's got a huge debt to
repay to John and he feels that very
strongly and fingers crusty does just
that right Isaac in certain spiritual
traditions the third eye refers to the
gift that leads to inner realms and
spaces of higher consciousness do you
think that applies to the three-eyed
Raven it's all about the ribbon ah yeah
I think in many ways it does because
I've always said that if I could have
any superpower it would be to be
all-knowing and that's exactly what bran
is now he's learned with the original
three-eyed raven and now he has access
to like this vast encyclopedia of all of
history and not only can he just read
someone's perspective of it he can
actually exist there in that time and
watch it happen so if that's not one of
the deepest and most interesting realms
there is then I'm not sure what what is
this is obviously very important those
questions grand illan if there were one
character Hodor
that US hadn't been killed put her here
with a big photo well I mean this to
people obviously one is someone who was
a magnificent presence in the series who
happens to be hosting this panel and
also Catelyn Stark big answer real
answer Alfie who died likes people back
to life yeah pretty much um I would say
Karl Drago
I like definitely felt over comic and
you oh you have to say that don't say
that okay not you Catelyn and no you um
I'm still hurting about Ned he'll break
my heart takes a while to get over that
one I also have a flame for Barristan
Selmy
oh we're not fasting I I just really
loved working with Jack Gleeson so much
that I have to say Joffrey
Wow it's such a good husband haha
sorry generals mother yeah I I have no
choice I have to say my baby girl serene
at still hordes big time I think I am
still heartbroken about her door like I
still I honestly just can't quite fit
into it but I you know I just love you
what your guys like whole thing so I
think my answer is is Hodel okay
like so many it to answers again first
and foremost become the illegitimate
Ares Robb Stark and the second answer is
if there's one character that I wish
they hadn't killed it'd be Jon Snow
just to say was having to talk about
every five minutes for a year
whole year was pretty bad that was a
pretty curl me yeah yeah you know I have
to go out in the newspapers if I thought
someone asked me for like 37th time the
hour is John snow coming back and I just
lost it I was like new off I don't care
yeah I'm next day in the paper it said
Christian hates hit hard thing like I
didn't say that
Isaac yeah you've been very careful Jay
yes some of the dollars I bring my photo
I could even like this are wolf step you
second legs actually so you after so
much time working on Game of Thrones are
you ready to act in a comedy rom-com or
a musical would you like to actor
director uh I feel like game thrones
incorporate rom-com musical you know uh
I don't know I like the dark gritty
stuff but I uh I don't know if I could
do comedy after all this I'm in a very
dark place in my life yeah take him that
she is let's see
Alfie yes would you like to be in a
rom-com or would you like to actor
director I know you love nothing more
than to be in a role nothing more yeah
no I mean yeah to just any anything that
comes my way you know even um you know
I'll just I'll just you know take
anything on but yeah directing is
something that would definitely interest
me without a job yeah come on
Gwen I'm desperate to do please someone
put me in a musical yeah kind of on a
nerdy tree kind of gender-bending sort
of song and dance
cabaret type thing maybe if I ask this
question
our prerequisite I want to ask you to
prove it but can you think I don't know
this I don't know the answer to that the
jury's out on that moral aspect of doing
a musical but I hear they can do all
sorts of Technology DJ it's called
miming okay
I took I'd like to being
gameís owned the comedy rom-com musical
Wow I hope that go well it would just be
a comedy rom-com musical and what more
might work might behind the door and
like tap dance yeah I mean you could
have all sorts of different musical
numbers it's it's ripe for a musical
adaptation shall we do it yeah David and
tan we just the people to do it you play
the piano
I enjoy the guitar they're sending me a
whole barn here actually John um when I
was 13 years old I played potty for the
plum role of potty far in Joseph and his
Amazing Technicolor Dreamcoat at school
well couldn't sing then can't sing now
absolutely stormed it somehow there nice
if so it'd be interesting to see how
standards of risen over time I'd be
interested in reprising my iconic role
as pasta for on the London stage for a
hefty old fee Liam I'd love to do some
comedy I did I did a lot of comedy on
stage before I started a television
business but I met peter dinklage peter
dinkledge was asked what did he think
drink the last episode ago and he thinks
the last episode of the entire show
should be a musical yeah I think it's a
brilliant idea
well we're breaking the norms with
television let's go that way let's
finish with a high kicking number around
it around the throne why not
I'd watch it yeah he'll be not as a
danger of doing it this way I've
forgotten who about conduct I am I'm
happy to take a rest and let other
people do wrong coms comedies and what
was the other one
it was oh no they're not getting to me
oh so now I've done it all
good night Wow Jacob yeah I want to I
want to make films but um that wasn't I
wasn't an option wrong carve you don't
again why really I'm like super greedy I
wouldn't you everything um yeah I it's
quite this is quite a hard show to
follow
I would you two like master Spears men
now this is hard and I'd so I just want
to do like hard things so I guess like a
comedy or a rom-com would be quite hard
I do want to you know because there's
this talk of spin-offs of the show I
just want to put my hat in the ring now
and just say I really like the idea I've
been talking to Daniel Portman he plays
pod and we've been talking about a sort
of side call to the show where grey worm
and pod and maybe Diana Harris a cyborg
side cool it's like ah so when you not
see I've already horn but will you get
like cameos like bran would come in and
be like that's a cyborg
I don't thought oh sure yeah Wow babe
let's go within cyborgs version I want
the cyborg version the Borg invade
Westeros could we do that please
actually I can announce that the HBO
spin-off has already been decided it's
going to be called better cold Davos
you're welcome and good night
[Applause]
Natalie yeah I am I'm sort of open to
all things I don't actually absolutist
for anything like I don't want to do
this I don't want to do that because you
never know what comes into your you know
email inbox you know you're like oh
that's a good script or that's be a fun
thing to do actually started off doing
musicals and so I am so open to doing a
musical whether I can sing as well as I
should I mean you know but I'd give it a
go and you know other staff like I'd
love to I've already still attempting to
write things and I'd love to be behind
the camera to say I'm so it was just
like going with the flow
awesome I think we've had some really
good ideas for a Borg Musical and
Westeros I'm going to start working in
that right away and now we're going to
open up the floor to you guys which is
the most important part of the panel I
phases which crowd is crazier the Game
of Thrones crown or Star Wars yeah
because people always ask me this and I
can't really I mean I should have come
up with a better answer by now really
there's absolutely no excuse I don't
think it's a I mean it's not really a
craziness but the level of passion is
pretty much equal and I'm hugely lucky
to be involved with both projects to be
involved with the project what is
noticeable is Star Wars is something
that many of us have grown up with that
gives us actually what I feel is a sense
of home about Star Wars that's how I
feel I feel like I've come home and it's
amazing the way Game of Thrones is 7
we're going into the seventh season now
but there's a similar feeling actually
which i think is much of the passion and
love and I look forward to the resonance
of Game of Thrones carrying on through
people's lives so they still have they
have that same feeling of home and
for it
[Applause]
hello my name's Lila from San Diego and
I just want to say your show is the best
show on television right now is you're
amazing I love it thank you
and my question is for Sophie um how is
your relationship with your with John
now that you've reunited and also since
you're running low on brothers lately I
have a proposition for you can I be a
stark yeah you can risk up yeah we have
a new star
easy as that see it was a easy to
replace brothers ah first question whoa
oh right um John and Sansa I've
forgotten the question what were
together again right together again how
does it feel losing - oh that's right um
it's it's you know there's still that
kind of sibling rivalry from back when
they were very young and they reunited
and there's still kind of those those
kind of that sexism that's just
ingrained in the culture where the men
are the the fighting figures and the
women just kind of say nothing when
really Sansa is politically especially
to do with battle of the bastards was
very she was very knowledgeable about
how to deal with the situation deal with
the Bolton's
and so it's about them finding that
balance and finding that collaboration
but it's it's proving quite difficult
he's the military man she's a politician
but I think they both need to realize
that they need to stop fighting for
ultimate power and just work together
this is for Gwendolyn now
tormund she seems to have only one move
with the ladies which is like the
same move I have which is a creepy smile
so what else would Corman what else
could she do to get in brands chain mail
wash well let's not forget
tormund does certainly have his very
well-put creepy smile he also enjoys
masticating food a prion as we saw him
really going down on that chicken leg
ah yeah it didn't do much for her did it
um I think really it's about really in
order to win Brienne's heart it's about
a mutual respect that isn't about any
sort of overpowering or sexual advance
it has to be about a mutual respect
that's born out of skill and uh and a
nobility about your ideals and you think
that's gonna happen with torment haha
yeah mutual rock it out with you
you know you might get lucky there are
kids out there are kids here so tell me
it's all Spiegel dragons
direwolves and three-eyed Ravens cannot
save you so are you looking forward to
rising again as the children of a cold
mic drop I've been here nobody knows
what you said dude this definite art
refers the first time we've heard the
night King speech are you looking
forward to rising again as the children
a little cold a great question we don't
have much choice in the matter do you ha
ha ha ha lutely nah I didn't realize the
night game is California hey I'm from
Philadelphia very good if the Manko made
you sound like you were from the valley
I'm only out here because of the Marine
Corps that's why the night Kings
formidable he was in the Marine Corps
thank you dude you look incredible yeah
you do about a beautiful car
[Applause]
you